elle ne s'appelle pas poufsouffle
gryffondor mais l'idée est la même c'est
maison référente qui fonctionneront
comme des micros conseils de vie pour
les élèves cet établissement situé au
coeur du val fourré est un nouveau
collège on pressent effectivement on
aura besoin on a besoin maintenant et
besoins
dans l'avenir de prendre en charge les
difficultés des élèves leurs besoins
parce qu'on est pas obligé par les
queues des difficultés sur tous les
temps l'enfant donc le périscolaire et
extrascolaire le scolaire bien entendu
avec l'aide des partenaires qu'ils
soient associatifs municipaux après deux
ans de travaux l'établissement a ouvert
ses portes le jeudi 2 septembre pour la
rentrée 2021 avec 600 élèves répartis
dans 28 classes les collèges ses années
chez nous ont été regroupées nous a très
bien le client s'est tout de suite senti
comme chez nous dans un collège tout à
fait normal je pense que ce collège et
bien il est beau il est grand défilé
cafétéria il se fait contrer fédérer des
maisons à mes potes et où un collège
pilote de par sa pédagogie et qui
pourrait voir d'autres établissements
créés sur le même modèle un projet porté
par le département et l'académie de
versailles pour un coût global d'environ
32 millions d'euros on a déjà un
programme de construction d'une dizaine
de nouveaux collèges puis au fur et à
mesure du temps qui passe on rénovera
des collèges donc on va s'inspirer des
échanges que nous aurons avec les
enseignants de cet établissement
son inauguration officielle pourrait
avoir lieu en novembre ou 2021 son nom
pourrait être dévoilée à cette occasion